LAKE HURON COMMITTEE INTO ALL
WHO ARE WITH US HERE IN
CHAMBERS AS WELL AS WATCHING ON
THE WEB WE WELCOME YOU TO THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA LAYS IN GERMAN.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE THREE HARD
WORKING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WILL
BE PRESENTING WITH THAT SEE
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE WE ALSO HAVE THREE BILLS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT. ON THE
PHONE TODAY WE GOT SANDRA COLIN
IS READY TO GO ON ALL ISSUES OF
KEEPING ROLE IN KEEPING US ON
TASK- SO WHY DON'T WE EAT CALL-
TO ORDER OFFICIALLY THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE FROM CALL VOTE THE
VOTE PLEASE MR NOW. SENATOR
MCGUIRE YOUR REQUIRE. PRESENT
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN PRES
SENATOR. DORADO PRESENT SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER. YOU
HAVE A QUOTE FORM IS BEEN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM IS BEEN
ESTABLISHED LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN BEFORE WE GET INTO
OUR SPECIFIC INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO PARTICIPATE TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO SEE IF THERE IS A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE OUR- ONSENT CALENDAR
ON WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
DRIVES SO THAT THERE ARE THREE
ITEMS IN OUR CONTENT COUNTER
ITEM TO ITEM FIVE ITEM SIX
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ITEM TO
ITEM FIVE ITEM SIX MOTION BY
SENATOR ALSO MISTER NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS
TO ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE
AYES SENATOR NIELSEN ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN HIS SENATOR DORADO
DORADO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG
SENATOR WIENER CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A THREE ZERO VOTE THREE ZERO
VOTE FOR THE COULD SINK COUNTER
GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN IN
ALLOWS THE MAJORITY LEADER IS
WELL AS CENTER WIENER WHO'S
CURRENTLY CARRYING HOUSING TO
BE ABLE TO JOIN ON IN JUST A
BIT- IN RESPONSE TO THE COPA
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATE
TORS AS WELL AS EMPLOYEES WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL. GATHERINGS TODAY
NEED HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AS
WELL- IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
ORDERS AT THE STATE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS IN
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC NOT AS
WELL AS ALL OF THOSE WHO ARE
WITH US HERE TODAY HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY VIA OUR
LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TALK
WITH US TODAY ON ANY BILL WE
WELCOME YOU. 877-226-8152 AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING HAVE A COMMENT
ON THE BILL PLEASE CALL US AT
877-226-8152 THE CODE TODAY
IT'S GOING TO BE ONE FIVE FIVE
FOUR ONE EIGHT THREE IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A PEN HANDY THAT
NUMBER AS WELL AS CODE IS ON
YOUR SCREEN. RIGHT NOW- THE
PUBLIC COM LADIES AND- YOUR BE
A PROBLEM BY A MODERATE AT A HE
IS WITH US TODAY WE PREACH. HIS
HARD WORK WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU- TO BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATORS DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. ON
ANY LEGISLATION. NOW TO BE ABLE
TO AVOID ANY FEEDBACK AT TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE THAT
YOU'RE WATCHING ON- PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. NOW IN THE UNLIKELY
EVENT THAT WE HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL BECOMES UNRULY.
AGAIN IT'S VERY UNLIKELY ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISTRACTED
MAY BE REMOVED FROM. THE REMOTE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE OR BE
REMOVED FROM THE CHAMBERS HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OF THE THREE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE HAVE
OUR FIRST AUTHOR WITH US. HIS
NAME IS EDUARDO GARCIA AMAZING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FROM DOWN
SOUTH WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF
HIS WORK- MR GARCIA YOU DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON YOUR BILL
TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED STATEMENT THAT WE
WELCOME YOU AND MR GARCIA THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK. SIR AND
WELCOME TO SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE. CARE CENTERS BE
SEVENTY SIX IS THAT WORKS THE
LIST OF. THAT QUALIFY. UNDER
THE CAPITAL INVESTMENT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS
ZIP. ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU AND THE
TEAM FOR PUTTING THOSE FORWARD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AYE MR GARCIA WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE TO WORK WITH
YOU TO LET AND JEM AND WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. CHECKING
IN WITH HER LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS HIS NAME IS SEAN WILCOX
HE'S WITH THE IMPERIAL VALLEY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. MISTER WILCOX
PLEASE AND MR GARCIA- BUT THAT
HE WILL BE SUBMITTING HIS
TESTIMONY IN WRITING WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH I MISS WILCOX WILL BE
PRESENTING. IN RIGHT HE'LL BE
PRESENTING HIS TESTIMONY IN
WRITING TODAY TO COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT. SO LAYS
IN GERMAN WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH- ARE- IN SUPPORT TESTIMONY
OF AB SEVEN TWENTY SIX THERE'S
THREE WAYS THAT FOLKS CAN.
PARTICIPATE THAT'S HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THAT SIMPLY OF
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
PARTICIPATE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. HEARING SEEN ON WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM TODAY TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANYONE IN OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM. WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
LEARNING AND MISTER CHAIR IT
DOES APPEAR THAT WE HAVE. ONE
WITNESS ON THE LINE HERE. OKAY
OUR MODERATOR AT GO RIGHT AHEAD
SIR. AND IF YOU- AND BELIEVE
THAT MR WILCOCK WAS THAT YOU
SERVE WERE YOU THIS. AMERICAN
LIFE. YES SIR I AM HERE. ALL
RIGHT MISTER WILCOX AND THIS
IS- SITTING GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE AT SO YOU DO
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR
TRUNCATED STATEMENT IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN TWENTY SIX MISTER
WILCOX MR WOKE UP WE- WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE IN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS SIR PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE
MY TESTIMONY TODAY MY NAME IS
SEAN WILL CAUCUS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED VICE PRESIDENT OF
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT AT
IMPERIAL VALLEY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION. POSTED
MEN MET THE CAPITAL THE CAPITAL
CONSENT OF. SMITH PROGRAM IS A
CRITICAL ELEMENT IN THE STATE'S
DEVELOPMENT OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY AND ITS
GOALS MOST IMPORTANTLY THOSE OF
US IN IMPERIAL COUNTY WHICH IS
VERY RECENTLY BEEN NICKNAMED
THE LITHIUM VALLEY A REGION
RICH IN LITHIUM DEPOSITS BUT
ALSO THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT
IN THE NATION. THIS INCENTIVE
WILL ALLOW US TO LEVERAGE OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES SUCH AS
LITHIUM FOR THE PRODUCTION OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE BATTERIES AND
WATER A CRITICAL COMPONENT IN
THE PRODUCTION OF RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN FOR HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
VEHICLES. LEVERAGING THESE
RESOURCES WILL ALLOW US TO
CREATE MUCH NEEDED EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR RESIDENTS
WHILE DIVERSIFYING OUR ECONOMY
AND BECOMING A LEADER IN THE
STATE'S. CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
SUPPLY CHAIN. THERE ARE MANY
OTHER COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LEADING THE
CHARGE IN THIS INDUSTRY. THAT
COULD BENEFIT FROM A PASSING
VOTE. OF AB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
TODAY THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS WELL COPPER
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE WITH US
TODAY TO GIVE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WE LOOKED AT FORTY TWO OH THREE
AS WELL AS OUR OVERFLOW ROOM.
HAD TO BE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT LAYS IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LIVE LINE TO BE
A CHECKING TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE. IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN TWENTY SIX MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TWENTY SIX.
NOW. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO PRESS ONE
AND ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. NO ONE IS SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO STAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
MOMENTARILY WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE GOING TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE
THREE WAYS TO BE TO PROVIDE
OPPOSITION FIRST AND FOREMOST
FOR GONNA LOOK HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. SEEN ON RISE OR NOT TO
BE GOING TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM.
A CHECKING WITH OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM. NO ONE IS IN OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR NOT
TO BE GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LIVE LINE TO BE
A TO DETERMINE IF WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUAL WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
IN OPPOSITION AND AB SEVEN
TWENTY SIX. MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION AB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
IF YOU CAN PLEASE GIVE THEM UP
NOW. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO MISTER
CHAIR KNOWN AS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A MODERATOR GONNA BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE DEBATED
SEIZURES QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
EMOTION BUT PLEASE WE HAVE A
QUESTION COMMENT FROM A CENTER
DROPS OF GOOD MORNING. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
GOOD MORNING- TO THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA- I WILL
BE SUPPORTING ON ONE
APPROPRIATE TO MOVE THE BILL I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR. EACH RECEIPT
OKAY- TIME I ESPECIALLY OF
SUPPORT OF THE- COMMITTEE
SERVICES AGREEMENT- THAT YOU
ARE INCLUDING WITH THE JOB
CREATION PLAN AND ON THE
ABILITY TO RECAPTURE THE
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS IF THE
FACILITY IS A RUN AS AS AGREED
UPON- I KNOW THERE'S REFERENCE
TO US WAGE. NOT LESS THAN THE
STATE AVERAGE CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW THAT WOULD BE DETERMINED OR
DO YOU HAVE AN IDEA WHAT THAT
IS NOW I JUST WANT TO GET A
SENSE OF WHERE IT. IT STANDS
CENTER I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION AND GET BACK
TO YOU- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE ARE JOBS THAT AT
HERE TO ALL OF THE STATE- WAGE
LAWS- WE ALSO ARE LOOKING AT-
TO ANOTHER PIECE OF LEGISLATION
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING. THE
SAME INDUSTRIES THAT WERE
HELPING TO BRING INTO THIS
ACCOUNTABILITY IS- WE HAVE A
BILL THAT WOULD WORK ON THE
COMMUNITY WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS
AS WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
HEALTH OF THE COMPONENTS ARE IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT THE LIVING
WAGE JOBS PEOPLE THAT ARE
TRAINED- AND DOWN IN THE
COMMUNITY GET ACCESS. TO THESE
POSSIBLE JOB OPPORTUNITIES
GREAT AND I JUST I ASKED THAT
BECAUSE I HAVE A- A BILL THAT
MIGHT OVERLAP A TEENY BIT ON
OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH CALLS FOR
JOBS PLAN. A LITTLE BIT MORE I
MEAN THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF IT IS
A LITTLE BIT MORE BUT I THINK
IT WORKS WELL WITH THE
INCENTIVES. AND THE RESPONSE OF
CREATING GOOD JOBS IN THIS IN
THE STATE SO PRECIADO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT SENATOR WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
LEADS ENGINE MOTION ON THE
FLOOR FROM CENTER DRAWS ONLY BE
SEVEN TWENTY SIX ELECTED TO SEE
THIS IN THE LAST CALL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS LAST CALL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
HEARINGS SEEN ON SOME NUMBER WE
LIKE TO CLOSE BY FRANCE FOR
RIVAL. RIGHT MOTION FOR FROM
SENATOR US OVER AND TURNED OVER
TO MR NOW- FOR ROLL CALL PLUS-
THE MOTION MISTER GONNA MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE- A SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN A SENATOR
DORADO DORADO. HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WINNER.
THREE ZERO CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
THREE ZERO VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER GARCIA WERE REALLY
GRATEFUL TO COULD YOU SEE SIR
AS ALWAYS INDEED WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE BRINGING UP OUR
NEXT AUTHOR ON IN THAT IS A
MEMBER ID GALLAGHER DECEMBER
GALLAGHER ALONG WITH THE GOOD
VICE CHAIR SENATOR NIELSEN HAVE
BEEN WORKING OVERTIME ON THE
REBUILD FOR THE CITY OF
PARADISE WHICH WAS DEVASTATED
BY A WILDFIRE HERE A FEW YEARS
BACK BY EACH INDIVIDUAL HAVE
REALLY BEEN GIVEN IT THEIR ALL
I TO BE ABLE TO. GET FOLKS BACK
INTO THEIR HOMES AND BUSINESSES
REOPENED WE WANTED KNOWLEDGE
THEM THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL-
THAT ESTIMATE WERE GALLAGHER IS
BRINGING FORWARD SUMMER
GALLAGHER WE DO WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW YOUR BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
YOUR BILL- AND WE WELCOME A
TRUNCATED VERSION YOUR
STATEMENT AND JUST WANT TO
PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR HARD
WORK ALONG WITH THAT MISTER
VICE CHAIRS HARD WORK TO
REBUILD. PARADISE SIR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. AS YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND- ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP- AS WE'VE BEEN.
TRYING TO FIND SOLUTIONS FOR
THIS THIS COMMUNITY THAT IS
TRULY BEEN. THROUGH SO MUCH
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD NEWS WERE
SEEN. HOUSES REBUILT-
BUSINESSES RE AND RE OPENING-
IN PARADISE IS A THERE'S VERY
MUCH A GREAT FEELING OF
RESILIENCE THERE- BECAUSE YOU
KNOW AND- WE- IS CONTINUE TO
TRY AND MAKE PROGRESS HERE AND
THIS WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT THIS
BILL AB THIRTY SIX TO BE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF. HELPING TO
BUILD- REBUILD THE WATER AND
SEWER AND ALTHOUGH TO ME TO
HAVE A SEWER- TREATMENT
FACILITY- AND SEWER OPTION FOR-
THE COMMERCIAL DISTRICT
PARADISO- APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT AND- WE DO HAVE SOME
WITNESSES HERE. IN SUPPORT OF
IT KEVIN PHILLIPS THE TOWN
MANAGER OF PARADISE AND ANDREW
MEREDITH FROM THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH INTEREST MEMBER LOOK I
THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS JUST A
NUMBER YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
GET THIS THING DONE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE I'VE WHICH THIS
LEGISLATION WILL. QUITE FRANKLY
IT WILL DO- AND TO BE A TO GET
FOLKS BACK INTO THEIR
BUSINESSES- IN IN THE TOWN THEY
CALL HOME SO THANK YOU AGAIN.
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK WE'RE
GOING TO WELCOME MISTER
PHILLIPS THE TOWN MANAGER FROM
THE TOWN OF PARADISE WHO'S WITH
US HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OF
FORTY TWO OR THREE MISTER.
MANAGER IT'S GOOD TO SEE
CERTAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU COMMITTEE- AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME O TESTIFY
ON THIS ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL-
FOR THE FOR THE TOWN OF
PARADISE- TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE. AND THIS BILL- ALLOWS
US TO SPEED UP TIME- FOR THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A
REBUILD- THERE'S TWO ITEMS HERE
THE SEWER PROJECTS AND THE
WATER PROJECT. AND THE SEWER
PROJECT ACTUALLY WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF ANY I ARE RIGHT NOW-
THIS WILL ALLOW. THE TOWN TO
REBUILD ITS BUSINESS CORRIDOR
AND TO FOR MULTI FAMILY DENSITY
THAT IS AND- SO NECESSARY IN
THE REBUILD OF OUR TOWN- WITH
FAT WE WITH THIS BILL. WE COULD
BE ACTUALLY BREAKING GROUND BY
NEXT YEAR OR THE YEAR OR THE
YEAR FOLLOWING AND THAT WOULD
BE A SUCH A BOOM. TO ALLOWING
US TO BASICALLY REBUILD THOSE
CORRIDORS. ON THE WATER SIDE
THIS BILL ALLOWS THE SAME TYPE
OF THING SO THAT WHEN A
DECISION IS MADE. AND ANY I ARE
IS ACTUALLY PERFORMED THIS GETS
THAT WATER LINE IN THE GROUND
QUICKLY. AND HELPS REVITALIZE
THE WATER SYSTEM UP THERE BUT
ALSO FOR THE INTERCONNECTED
BODY BETWEEN THE WATER. SYSTEMS
OF. PARADISE IN CHICO. SO I
THINK THE THAT. MULTI THE BILL
BENEFITS. AND I URGE A HIVE OF
THANK YOU. JUST A MAJOR IT'S
GOOD TO SEE SIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE NOW GOING
TO WELCOME MISTER MEREDITH-
FROM THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL DIRECTOR HE'S IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
DIRECTOR AT THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN CONSTRUCTION COUNCIL.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE SIR AT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SEE YOU TOO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK. ONE WORD
KNOWLEDGE US SENATOR NIELSEN
WHO'S ACTUALLY MY OWN STATE
SENATOR. IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
AS WE ALL KNOW TO. EIGHTEENS
CAMPFIRE WAS DEVASTATING FOR
THE TOWN OF PARADISE- I LIVE IN
THE NORTH STATE. AT THE TIME OF
THE FIRE WAS RUNNING THE
ELECTRICAL WORKERS UNION IN
CHICO I REMEMBER DRIVING INTO
THE OFFICE THAT MORNING. SEEING
THE FIRE AND EXPECTING IT WAS
GOING TO BE TRAGIC. NOTHING
PREPARED ME OR ANY OF THE
OTHER- PEOPLE THAT LIVED IN THE
NORTH STATE FOR JUST HOW
TRAGIC. THE FIRE TURNED OUT TO
BE- THROUGH THE HELP OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS LIKE ASSEMBLYMAN
GALLAGHER CENTER NIELSEN. AND
OTHER REPRESENTATIVES. THE TOWN
HAS REALLY. RESPONDED WITH
RESILIENCY AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
TRYING TO REBUILD. THERE ARE
BEEN SOME OPTICAL SOME
OBSTACLES IN THE WAY- ONE OF
THOSE HAS BEEN THE ISSUES
SURROUNDING SEWER. AND WATER
CONNECTIONS. UNFORTUNATELY A
WITHOUT THESE. ESSENTIAL
CONNECTIONS IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO MOVE
BACK TO PARADISE. THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE LIVING IN- THE
ANCILLARY TOWNS AROUND THE
COMMUNITY. THAT WANT TO MOVE
BACK- I'M GONNA USE THE FIRST
GUNS AND ROSES REFERENCE THAT
YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD ALL
SESSION. THE TOWN PARADISE CITY
BY GUNS AND ROSES. THERE'S A
LINE IN THE IN THE SONG THAT
SAYS TAKE TAKE ME HOME. THERE
ARE PEOPLE IN THE NORTH STATE
THAT ARE. THAT ARE YEARNING TO
GET BACK TO THE TOWN OF
PARADISE. WE THINK THIS BILL
HELPS ACCOMPLISH THOUGHT. WE
APPRECIATE THE BIPARTISAN WORK
THAT ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER IS
PUT IN. IN THE SUFFERS EVEN
GAUGE WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING. OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS BILL.
THE COMMITTED TO USING A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE.
THAT DOES EXIST IN BUTTE COUNTY
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT PUTTING OUR
MEMBERS TALK TO WORK THERE. IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY LOVE.
SO THEY CAN MOVE BACK THERE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
RED EVAN NO THIS IS VERY
PERSONAL FOR YOU SO VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT SIR. FACING
GENERAL WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
ASKING FOLKS TO BE TO PROVIDE A
SUPPORT ON AT FIRST IN LAST
NAME BASIS ALONG WITH THE
ORGANIZATION. THAT. TO THE
CHAMBERS HERE GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MAP
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND THE PARADISE YOUR
GEISHA DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SEE BROAD THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING. WHAT I
MISTER CHAIRMAN MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES ALSO IN SUPPORT. WES IS
BEEN HERE THROUGH THICK AND
THING- EACH YEAR INTO GOOD TO
SEE MISTER WEST VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT MASON GERMANS
CAN BE LAST CALL FOR IN PERSON
SUPPORT IN ROOM FORTY TWO THREE
LAST CALL FOR IN PERSON SUPPORT
AROUND FORTY TWO OR THREE. KERN
C. KNOWN RISE ARE NOT ONLY
GOING TO OVERFLOW ROOM. LET'S
CHECK TO SEE IF ANYONE ARE
BEFORE ROOM. CRICKETS IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GOING. TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LIFELINE. BERMAN ASKED THE
MODERATOR TO PLEASE Q. ANY
INDIVIDUAL UP. WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SIX WERE LOOKING FOR SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY SIX. MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE DO SO NOW. JOHN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN.
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE THIS ONE HERE ON YOUR G.
Q. WITHOUT. WE HAVE ONE PERSON
THAT TECHNO THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK- THAT PERSON BOB PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO GRAND LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AND WILL NOW HEAR FROM-
FROM. ONLINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- RICHARD BILL
GATES ON BEHALF OF THE
DEDICATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN COURT THANK YOU
THANKS SO MUCH RICHARD COULD
HEAR YOUR VOICE PRE SHEET THAT
SIR WE'RE GONNA DO A LAST CALL
LAST CALL FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
ON A TELECONFERENCE ON FOR A.
B. THIRTY SIX MISTER MODERATOR.
SURE NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU IN A
MOMENT MISTER MODERATOR THAT
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT NOW OVER TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO SB
THIRTY SIX WE'RE GONNA SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM.
TWO OR THREE HERE IN C. NOW AND
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM TO CHECK IN
THERE. NO ONE IS AN OVERFLOW
ROOM TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTY SIX. WE'RE NOT GONNA
TURN IT BACK TO OUR MODERATOR
MR MODERATOR. CAN YOU PLEASE Q.
OF ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF
AB THIRTY SIX NOW. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS. ONE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
KNOWN AS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS A MODERATOR AND BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE AND I'D LIKE
TO BETTER TURN THE FLOOR OVER
TO THE VICE CHAIR MISTER VICE
CHAIR SB THIRTY SIX. THIS
BRIEF- OBSERVATION. YOU KNOW
THIS WAS A GREAT TRAGEDY. THE
WHOLE TOWN. DEMOLISHED THIS
TERRIBLE FIRE. EIGHTY SIX
PEOPLE DIED. THE STORY OF THIRD
AYE SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD OVER
THE YEARS. WILL NOT BE THE FIRE
IT WILL RATHER BE HOW THE
PEOPLE OF THE COMMUNITY RALLIED
TOGETHER TO COME BACK AND HOW
QUICKLY THEY DID THAT. WE HAD
HELP FROM THE STATE IN MANY
WAYS BUT THE PEOPLE REALLY HAVE
RALLIED TO BRING THEIR TOWN
BACK AND- IT WILL BE BACK. WELL
SAID MISTER SENATOR AND I JUST-
THE SENATOR HAS DONE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WORK. ON
BEHALF OF THEIR BEHALF- HIS
MANY YEARS OF SERVICE YEAR WITH
THE LEGISLATURE JUST WON A
DOLLAR CHEN. MISTER VICE CHAIR
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK OF COURSE
ISN'T EVER GALLAGHER AS WELL-
INTAKE YOU IN A VERY ELOQUENT
IN YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IT'S
ALL HAPPENED BECAUSE- OF THE
NEIGHBORS IN PARADISO THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
BE A TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE A MOTION- EXCUSE ME ANY
OTHER COMMENTS PLEASE. MR
HOUSER IS FROM I WILL BE
SUPPORTING AND I ESPECIALLY-
ESPECIALLY SUPPORT THE FACT
THAT THE- A BUILDING THE
REBUILDING OF THE SUIT SEWER
AND WATER ARE PROJECTS WILL BE
DONE WITH SKILLED AND TRAINED
AND- REALLY QUALITY. ARE
TRAINED MEN AND WOMEN AND I
THINK THAT. WE LOOK FORWARD
THEN TO THE BEST. KIND OF
REBUILDING IN THE TOWN OF
PARADISO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MADAM SENATOR WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
THE VICE CHAIR MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY THE VICE CHAIR AT WORK
AND TURNED OVER TO US AND THEY
WERE GALLAGHER FOR ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THINK THE VICE
CHAIRMAN SOME TO. SUMMARIZE IT
VERY WELL- AND WITH THE G. AND
OUR- REFERENCE. HAVE FOR MISTER
MERRETT I THINK- WILL CONCLUDE
OUR REMARKS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALRIGHT THE
MOTION ON THE FLOOR ON AB
THIRTY SIX WE'RE GOING TO TURN
OVER TO MR NOW TO BE ON A CALL
THE VOTE AS WELL AS PROVIDE FOR
MOTION MR GRAMM. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST TO BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE MCGUIRE HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HIS SENATOR DORADO HI
DURAZO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER THREE ZERO
RESERVE A LAZY JOHN KEEP THAT
BILL OPEN BIRD ALLOWED THE
MAJORITY LEADER ALONG WITH
CENTER WIENER TO ADD ON THIS
GALLAGHER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK SIR GOOD TO SEE YOU
AS ALWAYS MISTER TOWN MANAGER
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND TO
ALL OF OUR OTHER WITNESSES SAID
PROVIDED TESTIMONY THANK YOU
THAT WE ARE NOW ON THE HUNT WE
ARE LOOKING FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. FREEMEN WERE. BLIND AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. FIFTY GIVE
US A FEW MOMENTS SERGEANTS ARE
ON THE SEARCH RIGHT NOW AND
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
GIVE US A FEW MOMENTS PLEASE.
PLEASE IN GERMAN A SIMILAR
FRIEDMAN DURING THESE DAYS IT'S
QUITE BUSY FOR A LOT OF NUMBERS
SHE'S CURRENTLY VOTING IN
COMMITTEE. WE'RE GOING TO
RECESS FOR A COUPLE OF MINUTES
WILL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS- AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR THAT WILL
BE OUR LAST. BILL FOR ACTION
TODAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
AGAIN AS A SENIOR IT'S A BUSY
TIME OF YEAR SO IT'S A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN IS SUPPOSED TO BE. IN
TWO PLACES AT ONCE. SO SHE HAS
NOT YET BEEN IST VOTING- IN THE
COMMITTEE THAT SHE'S SUPPOSED
TO BE AN AND WE WELCOME HER.
SOME GOOD NEWS DECEMBER
FRIEDMAN WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON YOUR BILL. SO WE
WELCOME A TRUNCATED VERSION
YOUR STATEMENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME AND
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD HAVING
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU I'VE ONLY
GOT ABOUT TEN MINUTES 2% SO.
I'M JUST KIDDING I THOUGHT YOU
KNOW I DIE I WANT TO FIRST OF
ALL THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL OVER THE PAST FEW
WEEKS I'M GOING TO BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE ADMINISTERS CUTS
BETWEEN OUR STAFF. AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR SIMPLY CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW TO ENSURE THAT
PERMITTING FEES. CHARGED BY
CITIES AND COUNTIES FOR HOMES
AND BUSINESSES TO INSTALL SOLAR
ARE REASONABLE. CONSISTENT
ACROSS THE STATE NOT USES A
REASON TO SOAK BUSINESSES AND
TO SOAK HOMEOWNERS. AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE AGAIN THAT IS SIMILAR
FRIEDMAN IS BRING IT HOME I
LOVE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND IT'S
BEEN A PLEASURE TO BE TO WORK
WITH YOU. WE HAVE ONE LEAD
WITNESS ON FILE TODAY THAT'S
BEEN DAVIS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION.
MISTER DAVIS YOU DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORTING COMMITTEE
SO WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR
TRUNCATED AT SUPPORT YEAH I'M
STATEMENT PLEASE SIR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING- CHAMBER CHOIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
WILL KEEP MY COMMENTS
TRUNCATED. WE REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS MORE
THAN SIX HUNDRED SOLAR
COMPANIES THAT DO BUSINESS IN
THE STATE. WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR A BE ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
BECAUSE IT WILL RESULT IN MORE
SOLAR GOING ON BRUCE AND GOING
ON PROPERTIES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I HAVEN'T ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
DAVIS. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE DOES
ANYONE ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STAND AT THIS TIME HEARING SEEN
KNOWN OR NOT TO BE GOING TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM. CURRENCY KNOWN
AN OVERFLOW ROOM LAYS IN GERMAN
COMMITTEE WERE NOT TO BE GOING
TO OUR LIVE LINE. WE'RE GONNA
BE ASKING ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. DEPLETES BE QUEUED UP NOW
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT. OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. NOW IF YOU WISH TO.
CONSERVE PLEASE PRESS ONE. BEEN
THERE ARE PRESS ONE. ZERO IF
YOU WISH. SPEAK CONSENT. OF IN
A GO TO LAW. THIRTY FIVE. HI
THIS IS MARK STIVERS THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS
MARK THANK YOU SO MUCH SIS GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WINE.
EIGHTEEN GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN PERSONALLY- FERRARI ON
BEHALF OF SOME POWER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR FOR OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINE THIRTY
HILL. GOOD MORNING JULIAN
MALADAPTIVE ALL I'LL BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH JULIE COULD HEAR
VOICE SIX CAR PLEASE. BLIND.
THIRTY ONE. GOOD MORNING
ANASTASIA CULTURE QUICK
CALIFORNIA VISORS ON BEHALF THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
IN THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU
THANKS ANASTASIA NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. PINE. THIRTY FOUR. GOOD
MORNING HERE ARE NUMBERS TO A
RAND OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION THE CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU KNOW THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
LINE FORTY. THANK YOU DON'T
DON'T ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION AND TO THE ETHICS
REPORT THANK YOU STONE LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WINANT. NINETEEN GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS REX
W. HìNH ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU REX NEXT CAR PLEASE.
MON TWELVE YES ONE ENSURING
MEMBERS JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
COBALT POWER SYSTEMS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU APPRECIATE
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S
GOT OUR NEXT CALLER. BUYING.
THIRTY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
MARGARET MILLER WITH ANGIE
NORTH AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH I MISS MILLER
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND. TWENTY SIX. I AM
CHEN HOME OWNERSHIP POWER BASED
ANTHONY ABOUT RETAIL AND
REINSTALL SHE TEXTURES AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL ITS
CURRENT X. COLOR. THE FINAL
CALL- TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO ON.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WHO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK CHáVEZ MODERATOR
LAYS IN GERMAN THAT WRAPS UP
OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES WERE NOT
GOING TO GO TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION LOOKING FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION HERE ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE HEARING NINE ONE NOW TO
BE GOING OR OVERFLOW ROOM WE
HAD CRICKETS ALL DAY. NOBODY'S
IN OUR OVERFLOW ROOM WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GONE FOR A LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LEVINE WE'RE
GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL THOSE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR NOW
OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. MISTER MODERATOR. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IN
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO. AND WE HAVE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO LINE. TWENTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING I CHAIR MEMBERS TREAT
THE RHINE WITH THAT WORLD
COUNTY RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE COMPANY.
CHINESE IN ORANGE PARK THE
CALIFORNIA. WE APPRECIATE
COMMITTEE AND THAT MEANT THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS TO TAKING VERY-
AND ALL WORK THAT THE DOCTOR
YOUR COMMITTEE. AND AUTHOR I'M
HAS DONE OVER THE LAST ACTUALLY
PROBABLY FORTY EIGHT HOURS WITH
US UNFORTUNATELY WE CONCEDED
THE OPPOSED MARK THE MANDATE
BUT WE WILL GIVE YOU THE
CONVERSATION AND HOPE THAT WE
CAN GET INTO A FIGHT- AT LEAST
NEUTRAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
THEIR RATES GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. A LINE. SEVEN ON
BEHALF OF THE BUILDING
OFFICIALS- WE'VE BEEN HUDDLING
GAUGING CONVERSATIONS- STILL
CONCERNED WITH THE CHANGING OF
THE DEFINITE DEFINITION OF
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS SO WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
OUT OF THE DAY THANK YOU I AM
SURE THE SINNERS AND KEEP
WORKING ON THAT THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. JOHN ANYONE
ELSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU MUST PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE NO
ONE ELSE THE SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK ALL RIGHT BRING
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
DECEIT IS QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
MOTION QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
MOTION. WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR ASSUME ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS HEARING
C. NINE. MADAM SOMEONE OR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE. RIGHT
NOW WITH THE OPPOSITION IS
REALLY ABOUT VERY TECHNICAL
DEFINITIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM- TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY'S COMFORTABLE
WITH THE BILL. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALL RIGHT SO AS A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN NOW IS YOUR CLOTHES
WERE VERY GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
DRIVES OKAY. MISTER NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE READ THE MOTION AND CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE
MCGUIRE HIS SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HIS SENATOR DORADO
DORADO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WINNER AT CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN TREES
ARE ABOUT KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE MAJORITY LEADERS WELL
CENTER WIENER. ALL RIGHT MASON
GENTLEMAN THREE ITEMS THAT WERE
ON OUR ACTION AGENDA TODAY
THREE ITEMS ON OUR CONSENT AND
WE'VE HAD IT. PRETTY GOOD IN
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS. AND GET READY
FOR SOME LONGER HEARINGS SO-
THEY'RE GONNA BE COMING UP-
HERE OVER THE NEXT. FEW WEEKS
AS WE MOVE IN JULY. SO WOULD
LIKE TO BE A QUICKLY LAY OUT.
THE REMAINDER OF THE HEARING.
CENTER DRAWS ON VICE YOU'RE
NIELSEN ARE FREE TO GO. WHAT'S
GOING TO HAVE TO HAPPEN NOW IS.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS. BECAUSE SENATOR WIENER
IS CURRENTLY CHAIRING HOUSING.
SO WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN IS I'M
GOING TO GO VOTE IN HOUSING- WE
WILL THEN BRING CENTER WIENER
BACK. IN WHAT WE'RE HOPING
EVERYBODY KNOCK ON WOOD WE'RE
BRINGING GOING TO BRING THE
MAJORITY LEADER. IN WITH
SENATOR WIENER IS WELL SO WE
GET THIS PUPPY DONE ALL AT
ONCE. EVERYBODY HAS SOME
SEPARATE ROLE YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S
ALMOST FRIDAY EVERYBODY SO
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS. WE'RE GONNA COME BACK
WITH CENTER WINNER IN CENTER
HERTZBERG. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
THEM ADD ON THEN WE'RE GONNA
SHUT IT DOWN FOR THE DAY ALL
RIGHT BRIEF RECESS WILL BE BACK.
I JUST WANT. PARTISAN YOUR
ORGAN BEING AFTER RECONVENING
HERE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE MR
MAJORITY LEADER IF YOU COULD
PLEASE TAKE NOTE AS A THE
MAJORITY LEADERS ALSO HISTORIAN
HERE THE LEGISLATURE CENTER
WIENER HAD- CAN KERN HEARING
HAPPENING IT'S AN WIENER WAS
VERY DOUBTFUL THAT GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE WOULD FINISH BEFORE
HOUSING AND IF YOU DON'T MIND
IS HELPING ME TAKE NOTE THAT
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WAS
INCREDIBLY. TODAY FINISH BEFORE
HOUSING DESPITE THE- THE
CHALLENGE THAT AS THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE HAD TO HAVE MISTER
MAJORITY LEADER NAFION
CONCENTRATION I THINK WE SHOULD
TO BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT OF THE
ENTIRE SENATE BODY INCLUDE THAT
INTO THE RECORD HISTORICAL
RECORD OF THE SENATE IS IT IS
INDEED QUITE IMPORTANT AND IDEA
I AGREE WITH YOU AND IDEA
APPLIED YOUR EFFICIENCY IN THAT
REGARD LIKE I SAID I'VE LEARNED
ALSO KNOW AS MAJORITY LEADER
SECURE EMERITUS AT THIS
CANADIAN HE REALLY SET A- TIGHT
STANDARD TO TIGHT SHIP INTO
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT. AND
IT'S. UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT.
I'M GONNA FOR THE THAT WHAT ARE.
AFTER I ON THE- THE CHAIRMAN
THE SIDE TO SELL AT A WITH. AND
THANK AS MANY. AND IT IS-
CHATTER AND SO THE IT WENT
QUICKLY SO THAT'S A THAT'S A
POSITIVE THING I SEE IT IS MY
WITNESS BY THE WAY EVERYBODY AT
IT IS SEEDS- THIRTY SECOND
BIRTHDAY TOMORROW. WHEN. THEY
SAID MY GOODNESS. CAN GRADUALLY.
MY CITIES WITNESS WE WERE THREE
LET'S GIVE A GETS GET IF I'M
CAR THERE YOU GO. EXACTLY SO
ALL RIGHT- IN ALL GOOD FUN WE
ARE SO GRATEFUL TO SENATOR
WIENER IN BEING PART OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE LOVE WORKING WITH
THEM. THAT'S A LAYS IN GERMAN
AND WE DEBATE THAT. IT WAS ON
THE WAY HOW MUCH WE LOVE
WORKOUT CENTER WIENER THERE WE
GO ALWAYS A PLEASURE OF.
SERVICE RIGHT IT'S AMAZING
GERMAN- WE HAVE FOUR ITEMS ON
THE DOCKET FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THERE ARE
THREE ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. TODAY AT WHAT WITH
ACTIVATED DO WE CURRENTLY HAVE
A AT THREE ZERO VOTE. FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MISTER
CONSULTANT IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND CINNAMON.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. BY WHICH
BURKE I SENATOR WIENER. ON
ANSWER THAT'S ITEMS TWO THREE
FIVE AND SIX EIGHT. TWO YES AT
TWO TWO FIVE AND SIX TO FIVE
OKAY ALL RIGHT WIENER HI. FIVE
ZERO VOTE DEAD DEAD THE
CALENDAR IS OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THE
ROLE NOW TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE A. B. THIRTY SIX
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO AT
MISTER NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE AYES SENATOR
WIENER AYE WIENER HI IT'S A
FIVE ZERO VOTE AB THIRTY SIX IS
OUR CLOSING THE ROMAN ARMY WILL
BE NINE TO A FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE THAT'S EIGHTY. SEVEN
TWENTY SIX CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO MISTER NOW SENATOR
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
AYES SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER
HI THAT IS A FINAL FINAL FIVE
ZERO VOTE THAT WE ARE NOW GOING
TO CLOSE THE ROLE FIZER VOTE ON
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX FINAL
ITEM FOR TODAY. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR KERN VOTE IS THREE ZERO
MISTER BURNETT SENATOR
HERTZBERG AYE. HERTZBERG HIS
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI BUT
THE FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT BILLS
THAT WERE CLOSE THE WRONG
REASON GERMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'LL SEE YOU BACK HERE. NEXT
THURSDAY THANK YOU FOR THE
ENTIRE TEAM AGAIN- AGAIN SOON
HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY SIR AND A
GREAT TIME WITH THE FAMILY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR- RIGHT
NOW BEEN ADJOURNED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH.